it took me the time it took me to get
back to me but i'm back
to me now nivea is getting a lot of love
following the release of a heartbreaking
new interview with candy burris
on her web series on that note the 39
year old singer who's currently one of
the singers featured on bet presents the
encore
recently went on candy's new show and
opened up about the ups and downs of her
career
that begin in the early 2000s i got real
real real real low and i never get that
low again thank you lord but i got so
low because i was depleted
i had nothing for me i wasn't i couldn't
inspire i couldn't be optimistic anymore
i couldn't pump myself back up out it
just wasn't i had nothing left
the laundromat singer burst onto the
scene in 2000 when she sang the hook on
mystical's hit single
danger been so long
[Music]
in 2001 she signed with jive records and
released her debut
solo single don't mess with my man
[Music]
and while nivea gained success and
admiration from fans
she says she struggled with substance
abuse failed romances and balancing
motherhood
all of which led to her fading away from
the public eye
in the hour-long interview nivea
detailed her former relationships with
rapper lil wayne
and ex-husband the dream alleging that
wayne whom she shares son neil carter
with
convinced her to leave her former
manager and record label
promising to take care of her
financially in return
okay come be with me i got you we was
young we were young
and i think at the time he was one of
those guys that
wanted to be a bigger or uh or
more on top or a person not a somebody
on your own
the singer recalled that she later
learned of his relationship with toyah
johnson
and the couple called off their
year-long engagement in 2003.
the singer then married r b singer and
producer of the dream
in 2004 and they had a daughter navy
talia nash
in 2005 followed by twin sons
london and christian nash in 2006.
the couple divorced in 2007 then nivea
got back together with wayne
the two were rumored to be engaged when
they announced their pregnancy in 2009
around the same time that lauren london
revealed she was also pregnant with
wayne's child
but nivea said she and lauren became
close during their pregnancies
and their friendship has lasted beyond
their respective relationships with
wayne
ironically lauren and i became like damn
sisters
really she really helped me through my
pregnancy
we really leaned on each other in fact
the actress was one of the first people
to respond to nivia's tell-all interview
commenting on her instagram post
promoting the interview
quote love you you are pure magic and
strength
toya also sent a message of love telling
nivia that she's so proud of her
and wayne and toyah's daughter echoed
her mom's sentiment
writing quote i just love you so much
one of the strongest people i know
as for candy she shared her thoughts on
her own account
writing in part quote i want to see her
win so bad
after you hear some of what she's been
through you're going to feel the same
way
i feel like your testimony or your story
i know it's cliche but it really
does help somebody else it does and i'm
a i'm a [ __ ] survivor
some people don't survive would have
never survived something
i did i'm so proud of myself now nivea
is starring on b-e-t presents the
encore a show where famous singers from
the 90s and 2000s live in a house
and try to make music together to form
the ultimate girl group
there's a reason that you are here
goodbye that's my final answer how are
we ever going to get anything done
and nivea says she's excited about her
next chapter
i have always been afraid to do reality
tv
but it was quite an experience and i did
learn
a lot about people i'm so me god can't
work through nothing
ain't authentic i believe that firmly so
hopefully
the things that i've chosen to share
touch somebody and make them
feel like damn well i can do it too
y'all
watch bt presents the encore of course
on nbt every wednesday night at 10
and i'm working on some new music so
just keep a look out for that